so far we've defined work in one
dimension but let's consider the path of
a particle in more than one dimension on
this screen it looks like a
two-dimensional path and here's our
particle and what we'd like to do is
define the concept of work for this type
of path now let's say that this instant
our particle is experiencing a force F
and the particle is being displaced by a
distance D s which is always tangent to
the path and what we'd like to do now is
talk about the work done for this
particle now what we'd like to first say
is what we're going to do is imagine
that we're gonna break the path down
into a bunch of small intervals and
let's call this the J the point and the
J plus 1 point then our particle will
start at J and will displace it Delta s
J to the J plus 1 position on the path
and here let's denote the force by FJ
and now what we'd like to do is define
the work for this particular section now
our concept of work is the force in the
direction of the displacement so what
I'd like to do is I'd like to define the
quantity F J and I'll put a little
parentheses upstairs a parallel lines
upstairs this is the component of the
force F J in the direction of Delta s J
now the way we denote that is we can
then say that if I take the dot product
of F J dot Delta s J this is the
component of the force in the direction
of the motion because remember our dot
product if we call this angle theta J is
taking how much of one vector is in the
direction of the other times the
magnitude of that displacement and again
when we write that component in
notation if we call this angle theta J
we know that that's the magnitude of F J
times sine of cosine of theta J now
because this is the amount of force in
the direction of the motion that's how
we've defined work done and we'll
symbolize the work done in taking the
particle from J - J plus 1 by the symbol
W J and now this is a scalar quantity
and when we want to find the total work
what we have to add up is from some
initial point to some final point how
much work is being done in taking our
particle from the initial position to
the final position and it's just the sum
for all of these J's and let's say we
have n of them of WJ and right now we're
going to call this W is just that scalar
sum and that's equal to the sum j goes
from 1 to N of F J dot Delta s J so now
we'll use the vector dot product because
we already know that this is how much of
the force is in the direction of the
motion however this answer depends on
how fine we broke up this path and what
we've seen many times now is that the
actual work that we want let's write
this as n because it depends on the
number of paths is the limit as n goes
to infinity of this sum of scalar
amounts of work now when we take that
limit as n goes to infinity of this sum
J equals 1 to N of F J dot Delta s J
this quantity is formally what we mean
by a line integral and we denote that
with a new notation we'll denote a line
from our initial to final and it's a dot
product of the force dotted into the
small displace
now whenever we see the dot product in
an integral that distinguishes it from a
normal integral because and this is what
we call a line integral now again why
did we switch from our Delta s s to DS
is because when we take the limit as n
goes to infinity
our grid becomes finer and finer and
finer until we're shrinking down to a
point where we can just talk about the
differential displacement DS and the
force acting on a point and that's what
our line integral is now what we'll
learn neck next is how to calculate this
line integral for a number of important
physical examples that occur in our
interest in mechanics